athletes are strong the crowd likes Ted
the ladies like you
you also gain muscle oh I would like to
be a professional singer one day you do
need to eat very healthy no days off
eat right Tino's player
it looks like some kind of smashed hair
it's never even heard of cheese may of
cashews
oh it's cheese it is I will totally eat
this my dad's name is Jack is it taste
like skunks in your mouth it's very
sweet
my candy but it's good for you thumbs up
I give it a thumbs down yeah it's most
like planet this green tea
hot-diggity-dog good one time I
accidentally ate grass and it tastes
like grass
it looks like yoghurt that's not
finished making so gooey and mushi he's
like my toilet paper have to eat this to
become a pro athlete now as analysis oh
no it's like a broccoli shake give me
the heebie jeebies hey slug sand
I mean it's Russell Wilson's he's pretty
muscular and I want to be at that level
so I think I drink this every day I
would give it know I'm actually kind of
impressed I'd have to go through this if
I had to be I would not do it I do still
want to be a professional athlete ears
walk yeah when you lose it it sucks when
you lose especially big games but you
learn that's what it takes so who those
cu athletes
then please leave one pizza break pizza
go save someone's life when them I'm
telling you